ذلك فيما تصف به الامم المتحده تصف منظمات
الامم المتحده ما يجري في منطقه القرن
الافريقي بالاسوا في العالم منذ اربعين
عاما ووفقا منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه لا
تزال توقعات العام الجاري في كل من
الصومال واثيوبيا وكينيا وبدرجه اقل
جيبوتي مقلقه للغايه تشير اخر التحديثات
الى ان عدد من سيدخلون مرحله الامن
الغذائي الطارئه سيصل بين شهرين ابريل
الحالي ويونيو المقبل الى نحو مليونين و
700 الف شخص وقد يصل اكثر من 700 الف شخص
الى مرحله انعدام الامن الغذائي الكارثي
في الفتره ذاتها ما يعني المجاعه او الموت
ويهدد سوء التغذيه الحاده ما يقارب 7
ملايين ونصف مليون طفل دون سني الخامسه
ووفق المنسق الانساني للامم المتحده في
الصومال لقيا 43 الف صومالي حتفهم العام
الماضي لاسباب مرتبطه بالجفاف كما تشير
تقارير الامم المتحده الى ان تسبب الجفاف
في تشريد مليون و700 الف شخص من منازلهم
في منطقه القرن الافريقي